nicolas bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors à quoi doit-on s'attendre avec la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
bonjour magali bonjour olivier alors ce
matin on va se régaler on va parler
désespérance pauvreté paupérisation fins
de mois difficiles et matin triste
rappelez-vous les mode emmanuel macron
on met un pognon de dengue dans les
minima sociaux et les gens sont quand
même pauvre il faut les responsabiliser
et bien voilà donc la réforme de
l'assurance chômage en chair et en os
qui revient sur le tapis social près de
850 mille personnes sont susceptibles de
subir une baisse de 20% de leurs
allocations
alors c'est sûrement pour bien
responsabiliser avant la grosse crise
économique du coït 19
alors quel est le menu rapidement et
socialement très épicé de cette réforme
rapidement durcissement d'ouverture des
droits rechargement qui passe de 4 à 6
mois de travail sur les 24 derniers mois
tout cela dépendra bien entendu d'une
baisse demandeurs d'emploi et d'un
volume d'embauchés le temps de donner
ensuite à prier la dégressivité de la
location sur les hautes rémunérations
plus de 4500 euros mensuels bruts pour
les moins de 57 ans vous avez aussi un
petit bonus malus les contrats courts
cdd pour les entreprises de certains
secteurs selon leurs résultats et ça
sera mis en place écoutez bien en
septembre 2022 je vous le donne en mille
c'est après la présidentielle et surtout
la modification du calcul du salaire
journalier de référence de la
sacro-sainte base de la location alors
quand j'entends certains éditorialistes
ergoter sur le planning le tempo ou la
pédagogie du gouvernement ben je
m'étonne je m'offusque que je
m'interroge car c'est regarder la
réforme d'assurance chômage par le petit
bout de la lorgnette médiatique et
politique car on va prendre de la
hauteur parce qu'on va supputer que
cette réforme d'assurance chômage
elle vient d'ailleurs il faut savoir
surtout regarder au bon endroit
alors où faut-il regarder selon vous et
bien du côté de ce maelström
technocratique weight également
chuchoter cette généreuse et joyeuse
réforme des retraites je veux bien
entendu parler de bruxelles oui car tout
vous le savez tout se décide à bruxelles
notamment la lumière des grandes
orientations de politique économique
autrement dit les go pay et des semestre
européen de suivi fondée en 2011
en gros
fisc et votre budget à paris et on le
fait corriger par bruxelles alors sachez
que la réforme l'assurance chômage avait
demandé par bruxelles depuis plusieurs
années un pour maintenir l'équilibré
donc la france est en retard sur ce
point et je vous dis à chaque fois
la commission européenne elle tient le
stylo des grandes réformes françaises
pourrait durer déficit améliorer la
compétitivité
finalement tous à favoriser la libre
concurrence vous le savez aussi
éradiquer la dépense publique tout
azimut et pour le comprendre il faut
s'imposer la lecture des textes
européens et je comprends pour certains
l'ennui à le faire et elle y passait ses
week-ends mais c'est pas marrant
finalement mais c'est très éclairant sur
ce que nous subissons aujourd'hui
alors nicolas pourquoi le gouvernement
at-il l'air si pressé de faire passer
cette réforme au 1er juillet réponse en
deux fois un premier point la crise
sanitaire a considérablement freiné les
réformes du manuel mâcon et le
calendrier il est très très très serré
d'ailleurs bruno le maire le ministre
qui implore et le ministre qui adjure
nous aussi prévenu mi février du retour
de la réforme des retraites car bruno le
maire est un technocrate prévoyants qui
ne perd jamais le nord bruxelles loi
deuxième point la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et celle des retraites sont les
deux réformes cardinal d'emmanuel macron
pourquoi parce que c'est la feuille de
route de nos politiques économiques et
sociales et je le dis tout le temps sur
internet
macron il est poussé emmanuel macron il
est poussé par une puissante idéologie
néolibérale et l'union européenne et que
l'outil finalement politique pour offrir
la france au marché avait la complicité
et contre l'avis du peuple du peuple
plus du tout souverain alors qu'on a
supprimé finalement là les taux de
chance et d'arrivée de l'euro pour
dévaluer et répondre aux crises et mais
il faut dégraisser le mammouth de la
dépense publique donc de la dépense
sociale comme valeur d'ajustement donc
de la réforme des retraites et de
l'assurance chômage
c'est absolument imparable alors on
entend et je le dis souvent langue
l'analyse politique qui essaie de nous
faire croire que macro 80 emmanuel
macron temps de donner des gages à
l'électorat de droite mais à mon sens
est une analyse erronée pourquoi parce
qu'il manuel mâcon entre nous entre nous
soit dit n'a pas prévu de présenter son
bilan politique ni à la droite ni à la
gauche ni en cours mais en français mais
à la sacro-sainte commission européenne
mais 2022 rappelez vous toujours la
feuille de route aller cet horizon
indépassable pour notre classe politique
alors il nous reste une minute nicolas
pour une ultime question ces réformes
pourrait-elle annoncé de nouvelles
mobilisations sociales on en a parlé l'a
récemment alors ça paraît inévitable
et curieusement un élément de réponse se
trouve du côté du fmi vous savez c'est
le fonds monétaire international dirigé
un temps par notre christine lagarde
nationale cette grande organisation
philanthropique tellement soucieuse des
citoyens du monde entier que leur impose
la mondialisation alors pourquoi
dans une note du fmi on apprend que
l'après coronavirus risquera de
déclencher une explosion sociale oui
vous entendu mais une explosion sociale
c'est donc la grande inquiétude du fmi
alors que cette menace se semblent
ignorer par certains de nos dirigeants
alors à ce rythme là il ne faudrait pas
que le fmi se transforme en ong pour la
sauvegarde et perdants de la
mondialisation
tout ça est à suivre merci pour toutes
ces bonnes nouvelles enfants tout cas
heureusement que vous êtes de bonne
humeur
nicolas un édito à retrouver bien
évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les comptes d'air france et on vous
retrouve jeudi prochain dans l'édito de
la matinale